Ahsoka reunites most of the surviving
members of the ghost crew from Star Wars
Rebels but the current whereabouts of
Zeb was until now a mystery however this
question is answered when a conversation
between Sabine Ren and Ezra Bridger
reveals that he's currently training the
next generation of Fighters for the new
Republic there's a new Republic STS
training recruits and Harris commanding
Fleet well there are many Star Wars fans
out there who want to see him join up
with his old comrades again it's good to
know that he's keeping busy of of course
zeb's current role in the galaxy far far
away was hinted at in the Mandalorian as
he makes an appearance in that show's
third season well this is basically a
throwaway scene in the grand scheme of
things it suggests that Zeb will have a
bigger role to play in Disney Plus's
liveaction Star Wars output in the near
future